when i work with data bind in knockout i
often get it a little bit wrong and
sometimes it feels discouraging so if
that happened to you during this
exercise it's not you it comes with the
territory and the best programmers can
keep their chin up and keep working at
it despite things breaking
also your solution may look different
from mine that's also okay
there are many ways of doing this so
look at my solution more for inspiration
rather than for the right answer that
said here's my solution first i added an
observable array in my view model i also
chose some of the cutest nicknames ever
tab at the tab tabby caddy cat
now in the html as you can see i added a
div down here for our nicknames and h3
to make it look pretty
and i made a ul with for each binding
this will take this li and do it again
and again and again for each of the
nicknames
and these lis have a text binding of
dollar sign data now i used dollar sign
data because i had to get to the actual
data in the array that we're looping
over
now this is great for simple things like
nicknames or months or lottery numbers
where the data is super simple just a
string or a number or a boolean for that
matter now if you filled your observable
array with objects on the other hand you
would write the name of the property
that you wanted out of the object this
is great when you're looping over
objects that are a bit more complicated
maybe objects that represent people or
products but in this case it's just a
bunch of strings